these days I'm a changed man I'm
different now um well you know who I am
my career Peter implanting sequence
complete hey everybody its charlie
apparently is just a week to dump all
the really cool Marvel stuff so we got a
new look at armor upgrades that we have
not seen before so I'll break it down
it doesn't confirm time jump but a lot
of websites a reporting time jump
because Iron Man supposedly has what
they're calling the mark 85 armor so
it's another one of those Ironman 3
situations where you go from the first
couple versions of the armor you jump a
whole bunch and you wind up in the 40s
so this time we're up in the 80s so if
this is gonna be our DJ's last big movie
appearance for good long wild then it
seems like he's going out in style
there's a new round of that spider-man
ps4 giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so obviously we have to
start with the Iron Man armor because
this seems pretty epic the most classic
of armors yet the most epic of upgrades
so the reason why I'm saying mark 85 is
because that's what websites are
reporting and apparently that's just
whoever dropped these pictures was
calling it mark 85 so what seems like
happened is is that these are pictures
that were given to the toy manufacturers
and that's where they're coming from
although I am partially convinced that
Marvel is quietly leaking little things
like this out because a little while ago
there was some concept art that I've
used in my videos before this big
picture that looks similar to some of
the character designs that showed up in
this new stuff that just dropped the
other day so if it's coming from a
couple of different sources and it's not
all the exact same piece of art then
there's got to be something behind it
Marvel is the master of marketing their
films quietly by leaking stuff to the
press early that's usually how it starts
before they start dropping official
stuff the weird thing about this though
is that whoever dropped these blurred
some of the body portions but you can
tell exactly what's going on so it
seemed kind of pointless so I don't know
why they would have done it because you
can clearly tell that this is meant to
be just like the Iron Man mark 4 with
the golden arms like very classic Iron
Man comic book armor yet because it's
the mark 85 it's like the Thanos buster
a quantum armor upgrade from the nanite
mark 50 that he was using
during infinity war now like a reference
Iron Man 3 so a little bit of time had
gone by when we picked up an Iron Man 3
he was still dealing with the trauma of
the Battle of New York and just spent
all of his time creating all kinds of
different armors so it wasn't like many
many years had gone by and he made one
armor per year he just made a whole
bunch of armors within the span of a
very short amount of time everything
we've seen so far and heard about his
arc during Avengers 4 is that he picks
up he's still in trauma he hasn't really
made that many armor upgrades there was
some concept art when they were first
dropping teasers for Avengers infinity
war that showed him inside his armory
inside the New Avengers base we still
haven't seen that so they probably
either cut that out completely in the
early stages of planning infinity war or
they just decided to move this scene to
Avengers 4 the whole idea being that
once he gets his together ant-man
teaches them about the quantum realm
they meet Captain Marvel they actually
have a plan for saving everyone and they
start running around doing things then
he starts iterating or there is a legit
time jump and this is somewhere further
in the future I think it's more
plausible that he just had a bunch of
different design changes that he went
through in the computer then he finally
found something that he liked he
fabricated that and that's why it's mark
85 the arc reactor is a little bit
different too but I'm assuming it works
the same way he has nanites within it
that build the suit around him but I
think just in general you can call this
version of the armor if this is gonna be
the final armor that he wears the
quantum fan owes Buster because why
wouldn't you try to power your armor up
with quantum energy you know obviously
it's gonna be them defeating Thanos and
even though his mark 50 was really
badass he didn't know that Thanos was
coming so in the way that he was
surprised by what happened with the Hulk
during the first Avengers movie by the
time you get to age of ultron he's
created Veronica the Hulkbuster same
idea with infinity war and Avengers 4
they encounter and lose to Thanos
he probably upgrades his armor to become
the Thanos Buster the war machine design
looks pretty much the same as we saw in
that previous concept art that I talked
about
remember the Russos teaser pic how a lot
of people wondered if this device was
going to be the proton cannon this
picture doesn't really do anything to
confirm that would
be surprised if Ironman I gave war
machines some of his nanite
hand-me-downs like that's the whole
thing is that Ironman introduces
something really cool
then slowly after a couple movies
warmachine gets his hands on some of the
tech like Ironman always gets the
coolest brand new version of whatever it
is that he's been working on cap scale
armor with the helmet looks on point we
saw some of these earlier this week so
people were talking about the scale
armor the rest of these pictures dropped
a little bit after that no sign of the
prototype shield that Ironman has been
working on since spider-man homecoming a
lot of theories about how that's gonna
work because it would make sense that
it's still vibranium but because of all
the nanotech I wouldn't be surprised if
it's like a combination of the energy
shield in the classic vibranium shield
so that it still looks like the classic
shield but it just forms around him the
same way that his Panther shield
gauntlets formed around him during
infinity war websites are reporting that
Thor has new armor in this picture but
to me honestly it looks the exact same
as the infinity war armor really the
biggest changes for him were getting the
cybernetic eye and getting Stormbreaker
and because that's meant to be the
ultimate weapon and it's already proven
itself capable of killing Thanos you
just need to go for the head they really
aren't that many upgrades do you could
give it Thor is about as powerful as
he's ever going to get we get some more
high-res pictures of Professor hope this
looks exactly the same as the armor that
we saw in the concept art previously
remember it's kind of silly for Hulk to
wear armor but is more meant to be a
functional piece of clothing that Banner
can walk around in and the Hulk at the
same time so that he doesn't shred his
pants every single time that he hooks
out Captain Marvel's costume looks
exactly like it did at the end of the
Captain Marvel trailer no real surprises
they're not expecting any big costume
upgrades between this the end of Captain
Marvel and the end of Avengers for more
pictures of Thanos in the full armor
with the sword and a repaired Infinity
Gauntlet with all the infinity gems in
it this looks exactly like the concept
art that we saw before so no real big
change since the last time we saw this
Black Widow with her red hair and blond
tip ponytail the only real reason why
they're leaving the tips blonde is just
to give you a sense of continuity
between the end of infinity war and what
she looked like in what she looks
like during Avengers for like little bit
of time has gone by they done some livin
they're all dealing with the trauma of
having lost to Thanos the last big one
probably one of the coolest because we
haven't seen too much of Hawkeye and his
Ronin gear or at least full Ronin gear
but you see him in the full ninja gear
with the stitch cowl and a sword no bow
in sight but we have seen him in behind
the scenes set picks with the boat so he
still uses a bow they just didn't
include it in this concept art I've
already done a couple Ronin Hawkeye
videos explaining why he looks like this
and how they're pulling from Easter eggs
in the comics and the secret invasion
aspects of it all the scrolls but let me
know in the comments what do you think
about all these new armor changes
particularly the Iron Man upgrade
because it seems pretty epic and it
sounds like something that they would do
like if this is gonna be our deejay is
the last big movie for a while we're
gonna do something really classic that's
a callback to the comics but really epic
at the same time and speaking of you
know coming back I think we'll all
expect some of these people even if they
don't come back for a while to come back
for some huge secret Wars style giant
multiverse crossover in many many years
in the future no ideas when they would
actually do that but speaking of big
x-men crossover they are dropping the
first official Dark Phoenix trailer
tonight of course I'll do a video for it
they didn't say what time so just be
looking at my Twitter feed I'll tell
everybody when it drops I'll start
working on my video so we can freak out
about that later I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post that so click here to
learn more about what's going on with
Hawkeye and click here to learn all
about black costume Tom Hollands
spider-man during far from home thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]